nos piden representar la desigualdad que
mayor que 5 en la recta numérica y en el
plano coordenada hagamos primero en la
recta numérica dibujemos entonces
nuestra recta numérica aquí tenemos la
recta numérica ubicamos aquí el 0 hacia
acá estarán los negativos aunque más
bien los nuevos se enfocan en los
positivos porque no están pidiendo mayor
que 5 ubicamos 5 1 2 3 4 5 aquí tenemos
5 chequemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y así
sucesivamente los valores mayores que 5
esté la recta que estamos llevando hoy
esta recta numérica y queremos los
valores mayores que 5 es decir no
queremos incluir al 5 si fuera mayor o
igual a 5 incluiremos al 5 pero creemos
mayores que 5 así es que marcamos eso
con un círculo abierto con un círculo
abierto estamos indicando que no estamos
incluyendo el 5 y hacia la derecha
estarían los números mayores que 5 si
nos pidieran mayor o igual a 5
llenaríamos este círculo para indicar
que estamos incluyendo el 5
representamos ahora la desigualdad en el
plano coordenada
dibujemos el plano coordenada aquí
tenemos el eje vertical este eje
vertical es el eje y de acuerdo a la
convención usual mientras que el eje
horizontal es el eje x tenemos algunos
valores para i
1 2 3 4 5 ahí tenemos 5 6 7 y así
seguiría para valores cada vez mayores y
queremos mayor que 5 no va a ser mayor o
igual a 5 por lo cual no vamos a incluir
ya igual a 5 por lo cual la recta igual
a 5
la dibujaremos con una línea discontinua
esto nos muestra que no estamos
incluyendo ye igual a 5 pero si queremos
incluir todos los valores que son
mayores que sí para esto sombrear hemos
vamos a sombrear esta zona que
representa la región donde los valores
de iu son mayores que 5 si hubiera sido
mayor o igual a 5 incluiríamos una línea
continua aquí en esta región que hemos
dibujado no importa cuál es el valor de
x que tomemos que va a ser mayor que 5